Peter let's talk about the first step in
writing a screenplay
yeah the first step is what turns you on
that's always what it is you should
never write to the market the market
will always horrify you right now it's
selling our superhero stories to the
studios but if you don't like writing
superhero stories you shouldn't say oh
well I'm going to write one anyway
because you'll fail you have to write
from passion and my experience yes even
writers who are professionals you write
from what you love and you write from
what embarrasses you and you write from
your core wounds we all have things that
we love to talk about and those come
from our core wounds and I say every
storyteller is wounded and their time to
tell a story to heal that wound we all
have a dozen core wounds I'm ugly my
mother didn't love me I'm badly
socialized no one understands me I go to
a party I can't talk to me but no one
will listen to me I'm lonely I'm alone I
can't reach out I'm married but I'm I'm
not happy because I really can't be
myself there's all these wounds we all
have and we carry them inside ourselves
that's really what we're always writing
about always and this is true for unthe
era pies writers who are very successful
even if they never looked at a
psychologist couch and they laugh at
this when I work with them turns out
what they're writing about always is
their core wound so ask yourself as a
storyteller I don't what I'm interested
in what are the movies I love I
guarantee you when you do that you'll
find out that is your place where you
need to start are you didn't love now
I'm interested in computers well then
you might want to write a sci-fi movie
because you're sort of mechana sized and
and that's your that's your bliss but I
guarantee you that comes from a core one
too so you must start with what excites
you and then shaping it is just a matter
of after you've done a passion
draft what I call just a draft of
whatever you want your story to be about
it could be a paragraph it could be a
line it could be 50 pages then it's time
to think about I don't want to shape
this because the shape is always going
to be the same if it's a movie or a
television show the shape will always be
the same and learning what that shape is
is your job as a screenwriter is your
job as a television writer but it must
have come from your passion I always
asked my class stand up right now and
tell me the most embarrassing thing
about yourself you could ever tell
anyone the thing that would make you
cringe horribly if anybody knew it can
you stand up and do that of course no
one will so I do I stand up and I say
look at my face
and when you look at now I want you to
shout this out but when you look in my
face tell pick out the worst feature in
my face on the best feature don't tell
me because I did a Korean television
interview or a while ago on the goggles
you have a giant mole on your cheek and
I'm like which I didn't really want to
know that but just tell me but just have
it in your head what's my best feature
and my worst feature okay now most
people pick one thing out and the other
then they start telling you no I don't
want to tell them I know what it is now
I say okay now I'm going to tell you a
secret about myself something really
embarrassing when I was a teenager I had
this problem and it was a very
embarrassing problem I had something
called body dysmorphia and I don't know
if you know what that is but it makes
you feel like you either have something
too big or too small about your parents
I thought that my lips were the size of
Mick Jagger so that when I would go into
a room I thought everyone was staring at
my lips they were huge
I'd knock people over with my I wouldn't
kiss a girl in high school because I was
afraid my lips would get wet and then
they would look even bigger so here's
what I did about that
all these things came out of that wound
in high school for me one I wore white
chapstick okay
which made me appear I was wearing
lipstick now I had long hair and I was
in a band so every time someone will
look at me I'd be thinking
they're looking at my lips are huge no
they were looking the fact that dudes as
long here he's wearing lipstick he must
be gay that's not what I thought I would
to also eat my lunch in the bathroom
because I didn't want people to see my
wet lips so you see that this one wound
oh by the way I got therapy I'm over it
now but this one wound was motivating
all these things they did I wouldn't
have a girlfriend actually I was a
pretty good looking guy in high school
but I couldn't do it because I actually
did have some but it was a horrible
experience because every time I kiss
them I'd have to use the white chapstick
so you see where I'm going when I tell
people this story they're like first of
all they're sort of uncomfortable and
then they kind of want to laugh and then
they're just interested because it's
true anything you tell about yourself
that's true that's embarrassing is
fascinating to an audience
all great story comes from these kinds
of confessions I call them this is a
device you use to make your hero
compelling it's a confession of some
embarrassment that you had in your life
we love to see that because we're all
embarrassed we all feel these wounds we
all have them and we see them in a story
we recognize them as real and we love
that person and we want that person
we're rooting for that person every
great story starts with a character
wounded like this unless it's a super
hero that's a that's a separate genre
that has their own rules but most of the
movies you love have a hero who's
wounded and it comes from the writer
himself and the wounds that he has and
how he tries to compensate for those
that's the physical manifestations in
the story of his behavior me hiding in
the bathroom me wearing white chapstick
I played football but I wore white
chapstick contradictions why I was a big
guy but long hair lipstick and I didn't
know it I thought people were staring
because of my lips no they weren't so
all these things you don't know about
yourself learning them is a story that's
what makes great
you